I have extremely bad news Halloween
falls this year on a Sunday the we in
603 for refused to suffer the slings and
arrows of outrageous fortune so we've
decided that Halloween is today as far
as 603 for is concerned Kenny could you
give me a hand please that put it over
there just give it to them you can take
as much of this as you like the rest
will be given to that herd of stampeding
freshmen that comes in after it's a
cornucopia of legal drugs chocolate does
produce a kind of mild high and I
recommend it before quizzes and giving
lectures at I have a friend of mine one
of the Nobel laureates in biology
always eat chocolate before he lectures
given the ledge otherwise it would be
flat so I recommend it
it will take I suppose a little while to
digest that neural net stuff richer than
usual in mathematics so we're today
we're going to talk about another effort
at mimicking biology this is a this is
easy stuff
it's just conceptual and you won't see
this on the next quiz but you will see
it on the final it's one of those quiz 5
type problems or you ask you questions
to see if you were here and awake so
typical question might be professional
professor Winston is a creationist or
something like that not too hard to
answer in any of that if it's been hard
to develop a real understanding of
intelligence occasionally the hope is
that by mimicking biology or mimicking
evolution you can circumnavigate all the
problems and one of those kinds of
efforts is ever to imitate evolution so
we're going to talk today about
so-called genetic algorithms which are
naive attempts to mimic naive evolution
now I realize that most MIT students
have a basic grasp of sexual
reproduction but I found in talking with
students said many times the details a
little fuzzy on some of the details so
let's start off by reflecting a little
bit on how that works so let's say we
need pink and blue and here's our cell
and here's its nucleus and here our
mummy and daddys chromosomes we'll just
pretend there's one pair now ordinarily
an ordinary cell division
you get two cells will have a nucleus
and the process of producing them
involves the duplication of those
chromosomes
and then one pair ends up in each of the
child cells and that's all ours to that
that's mitosis but then when we talk
about reproduction it's a more
complicated because the those
chromosomes get all twisted up and a
break and they recombine so when we talk
about the cells that split off from one
of these germ cells it's no longer
appropriate to talk about the pink one
and the blue one because they think one
and a blue one are all mixed up so you
get two chromosomes here and two here
but through some miracle of nature which
is always amazed me these two cells
split in turn and to four cells all
together and each of those four cells at
the bottom gets one of the chromosomes
that was produced by that twisting up of
the rope and recombination then along
comes along comes a special occasion and
now I can think of this as being a blue
one and this is being a pink one and
they come together and you get a new
person like so note that your mother and
father's chromosomes are never never
recombined it's your grandparents
chromosomes that we combine so that's
what it's like and the main thing to
note about this is well are a couple
things if you happen to be female this
part of the process this part over here
took place before you were born if you
happen to be male it's going on right
now as we speak which probably explains
something any event it's going on right
now but whenever it goes on there are
lots of opportunities
or for throwing dice so God threw all
the dice before you were born and you
happen to be a female in this part of
the process over here then of course
more dice got thrown here when the
decision was made about which particular
cells got to fuse to form a new
individual so I want to beat on this
idea of lots of choice when we talk
about genetic genetic algorithms we talk
about nature there there are lots of
choices in there and that means there
are lots of choices to intervene to
screw around to make things work out the
way you want any of it there we are
that's the basic idea and it all starts
with chromosomes so we could think of
implementing something that imitates
that with the ACTG
stuff that you learned about all about
701 but we're computer scientists we
don't like base for we like base too so
I'm going to just suggest that our
chromosomes are binary in this system
that we're going to build so that might
be a chromosome it doesn't have to be
binary it can be it could be symbolic
for all I care but it's just some string
of things that determine how the
ultimate system behaves so it all starts
out then with some of these chromosomes
some of these simulated chromosomes
simulated simplified and naive and
there's a population of chromosomes the
population of chromosomes that might be
subject to a little bit of mutation that
is to say a 0 becomes a 1 or 1 becomes a
0 that happens a lot of that mutation
stuff happens over here when things get
twisted up and recombine they're copying
errors and stuff
cosmic rays hit it all the time all
sorts of reasons why there might be a
single single pointed change that one
that produces the mutation effect so
here we have a population
it starts off over here and it's some of
those things are subject to mutation and
you'll note here here's a whole bunch of
choice already how many of these
mutations do you allow per chromosome
for example how many of the chromosomes
just slipped through without any
mutation those are choices you can make
once you've made those choices then we
have the crossover phenomenon let's
identify one of these guys as the pink
one and one of these guys is the blue
one and so now we have the pink one
cruising along as well as the blue one
the pink one and a blue one cross and
produce a new chromosome just like in
nature so we take the front part of one
back part of the other and we fuse them
together and some may slip by without
any of that like so well these these
things are meant to be combined in pairs
like so but they may not they may not
have any crossover in them so another
you have another set of choices how many
crossovers do you allow per
recombination get another set of choices
so now we've got a population of
modified chromosomes through mutation
and crossover so the next thing to do is
we have the genotype to phenotype
transition that is to say the the
chromosome determines the individual it
may be a person that may be a cow may be
a computer program I don't care what but
that that code down there has to be
interpreted to be a something so it is
the genotype and it has to be
interpreted to be something which is the
phenotype the thing that the stuff down
there is encoding for so out here we
have a bunch of individuals
now each of those individuals because
they have varying chromosomal
composition will have a different
fitness
so these Fitness's might be who knows
they might how they might be scored but
for computer scientists we might as well
use numbers so maybe this guy's Fitness
is 88 this guy's Fitness is 77 and so on
so now that we've got Fitness by the way
notice all the choices involved their
choice how you interpret the genotype
choice about how the phenotype produces
the Fitness and now we have a choice
about how the Fitness produces the
probability like point eight and point
one or something like that probability
of survival into the next generation so
now once we've got those probabilities
we actually have selection and those
phenotypes out there produce genotypes a
new set of chromosomes and that
completes our loop that goes back in
there and so that's a new generation it
sounds simple so if you're going to make
this work of course you have a million
choices I'm going to emphasize over and
over again and one of your choices is
for example how do you compute the
Fitness how do you compute the
probability of survival to the next
generation given the fitness so we have
to go somehow from numbers like these
two probabilities like those so I'm
going to talk about several ways of
doing it none of them are magic none of
them was specified and stipulated by God
is the right way but they have
increasingly good properties with
respect to this kind of processing so
the simplest thing you can do idea
number one for computing the probability
what you do is you get this whole bag of
individuals and you have to decide who's
going to survive the next generation
so at each step everything in the bag
has a probability of being the one you
pick out and put into the next
generation
so at any step the sum of the
probabilities for each of those guys
goes is one because that's how
probability works probability of a
complete set is outlined all up is
probability one so one thing you can do
is you could say that the probability
that you're going to draw individual I
is equal to or maybe proportional to the
fitness of that individual I haven't
completed the expression so that's why I
haven't completed the expression so it's
not a probability yet because some of
our piece of I want won't add up to one
how could I ensure that it will add up
to 1 oh that's easy
right all I have to do is divide by the
sum of the Fitness that's over I so
there's a probability measure that's
produced from the Fitness's have to make
sure the Fitness is or what he says I
have to make sure the Fitness is our
negative V I would be embarrassing if
they were so we'll just truncate
anything like that at zero V you got a
lot of choice how you can calculate the
Fitness and maybe you will produce
negative numbers in which case you have
to think a little bit more about it so
now what about an example well I'm going
to show you an example why don't I show
you the example what we're going to do
is we're going to have a genetic
algorithm that looks for an optimal
value in a space and there's the space
and you'll notice it's a bunch of
contour lines bunch of hills in that
space let me show you how that space was
produced the Fitness is a function of x
and y and it's equal to the sine of some
constant times X quantity squared times
the sine of some constant Y quantity
squared
E
to the plus X plus y divided by some
constant so Sigma and Omega there are
just in there so that it kind of makes a
nice a nice picture for demonstration so
there's a space and clearly where you
want to be in this space is in the upper
right hand corner that's the optimal
value but we have a genetic algorithm
doesn't know anything all it knows how
to do is mutate and cross over so it's
going to start off with a population of
1 it's a little red dot down there in
the lower left so here's how it's going
to evolve there's going to be a
chromosome consisting of two numbers an
X number and a Y number like say point
three and point seven here's another one
which might be 0.6 and point two so the
mutation operator is going to take one
of those values and change it a little
bit so it might say well okay three and
we'll make it point two and the
crossover operation is going to exchange
the x and y values of pairs so if we
have a cross over here
then what we're going to get out from
this one well we're going to get out a
combination of these two and it's going
to look like this that's what we're
going to do is we're going to take the x
value of one and combine it with a Y
value the other one so this is going to
be point to my mutated value and point
two and this is going to be 0.6 0.7 so
that's how my little genetic algorithm
hack is going to work so having coded
this up we can now see how how it how it
flows oh let's run at ten generations
so the population is rapidly expanded to
some fixed limit I forgot what it is
thirty or so and we can run out of
hundred generations and so this seems to
be getting stuck kind of right so what's
the problem the problem is local Maxima
this is fundamentally a hill climbing
mechanism you note that I have not
included any crossover so far so if I do
have crossover then if I've got a good
xvalue and a good y-value and I can
cross them over and get them both into
the same and the same in the same
situation but nevertheless this thing
doesn't seem to be working very well
yeah just contour lines of that function
so the reason you see a lot of contour
lines in the upper right is because it
gets much higher because there's that
exponential term it increases as you go
up to the right so I don't know let's uh
let's put some crossover in and repeat
the experience one of honored
generations
I don't know it just doesn't seem to be
going anywhere
sometimes it will go right to the right
to the global maximum sometimes it takes
a long time it's it's got a random
number generator in there so I have no
control over it so it's going to get
there I couldn't tell whether the
crossover was doing any good or not oh
well here's one let's put it a little
big this a little bit more complicated
suppose that's the space
now it's going to be in real trouble
because it will never get across that
moat you know you would think that it
will climb up to 1 1 2 to the X maximum
into the Y maximum but it's it's not
going to do very well
even with cross over it's just not going
to do very well because it's climbing up
those local hills anybody got an idea
about one simple thing we could do to to
make it work better yeah you could
increase the step size right you see
that will help
you know even that doesn't seem to help
so we have to conclude do we conclude
that this is a bad idea well we don't
have to concludes a bad idea yet because
uh we may just look at it and ask why
five times and we might ask well maybe
we can get a better fitness a better
mechanism in there to translate Fitness
into probability of survival
you know these using that using this
formula is kind of strange anyway
because you know if you suppose
temperature is one of your fitness
characteristics the hotter the better
then the ratio of the probability you
will survive versus some person next to
you
that ratio will depend on where you are
measuring the temperature in Celsius or
Fahrenheit right because you've shifted
the you shifted the origin that shifts
the ratio that shifts the probability of
success so it seems kind of strange to
just take these things right straight
into probabilities so a better idea idea
number two is to say well shoot maybe we
don't care about what the actual
Fitness's are all we really care about
is the rank order of all the candidates
so the candidate with the most fitness
will have the most probability of
getting into the next generation
the candidate with the second most
fitness will have the second highest
probability and so on but we're not
going to use the actual Fitness is
themselves to make the determination
instead what we're going to do with this
mechanism number two this is the rank
space method is this we're going to say
that the probability of the
highest-ranking individual getting into
the next generation is sub some constant
P sub C which of course you could select
yet another choice then if if that guy
doesn't get selected the probability of
the second highest-ranking
individual getting in the next
generation is going to be the
probability that that guy didn't get in
there that's one minus P sub C times the
same probability constant and so you can
see how this is going
P 3 will be equal to 1 minus P sub C
squared times P sub C P sub and minus 1
will be equal to 1 minus that
probability constant to the N minus n
minus 2 times P sub C and then there's
only one individual left I mean if
you've got through all these guys and
haven't got anybody selected then you've
got to select the last guy and so the
probability you're going to select the
last guy is going to be 1 minus P sub C
the N minus 1 so it's it's it's a
probability you've missed all of those
guys at first and n minus 1 choices got
it is honest to God
see it's the probability this is the
probability that this last guy is going
to get selected it's not the probability
of the last guy getting selected given
that the others haven't been selected
trust me it's right I think it ought to
be one where you think it ought to be
one
no you are rolling the dice you got a
probability each time except for the
last time when I push it you have to
take it there's nothing left there's
other choice yeah
versus the second choice I probably why
- because you guys didn't see no no see
well think about it this way it's the
probability you didn't choose the first
two
so the probability I didn't choose the
first one is 1 minus P sub C the
probability didn't choose the next one
as well as because you're choosing that
next one with probability P sub C it's
it's the square of it okay so that's a
that might be men might work better
let's give it a shot let's go back to
our original space choice and reset and
switch to a fitness the rank fitness
method and we run out a hundred
generations Bo and what happened there
that was pretty fast maybe I use a big
step size yeah that's a little bit more
reasonable oops
what happened it's really getting stuck
on a local maximum so evidently I've
choose two constant P sub C such that it
just drove it right up the nearest hill
on the other hand if I change the step
size a little bit maybe I get it to
spread out I sure did
and now that it's managed to evolve over
there to find the maximum value now I
can clamp down on the step size again
and now it shows them where diversity
it's just locked on to that global
maximum so this is not unlike what
evolution sometimes does it
sometimes species collapse into a state
where they don't change from five or six
hundred million years like sharks for
example sometimes they need sometimes
they only survive if they've got a lot
of diversity built into their way of
life so that they can adjust to habitat
changes now when you increase the step
size because you're stuck on a local
maximum
it's like heating up a metal you make
everything kind of vibrate more make
bigger steps so this this kind of
process where you may start with a big
step size and then gradually reduce the
step size is called simulated annealing
because it's like letting a metal cool
down so you start off with a big
temperature big step size that kind of
covers the space and then you slowly
reduce the step size so you so you
actually crawl up to the local maximum
of their local Maxima they're available
so that seemed to work pretty well let's
see if we can get it to work on the
harder problem with the moat
so it's a not doing very well better
increase the step size now it's still
kind of stuck it's even though it even
though it's got the capacity to cross
over its so stuck on that lower right
hand corner it can't get up the that
vertical branch to get to a point where
crossover will will produce a value up
there in the upper right hand corner so
we're still not home yet so what's the
trouble the trouble is that the fitness
mesh the fitness mechanism is just
driving things up the local maximum
it's just terribly unfortunately what to
do well here's something you can do you
can say well if if the problem is we
we've lost the diversity in our
population then we can measure the
diversity not only the fitness of the
the set of individuals were selecting
from but we can measure how different
they are from the individuals we've
already selected for the next population
in other words we can factor in we can
get a diverse population as well as a
fit population if when we make our
selection we consider not only their
fitness but how different they are from
the individuals have already been
selected so that's going to be mechanism
number three
so now we have a a space and we can
measure Fitness along one axis ordinary
Fitness and this is rank space Fitness
so that's going to be piece of C
there'll always be some individual with
probably with the highest fitness and
and over here that might not be piece of
C actually but there'll be some
individual with a maximal fitness and at
any given step in the selection of the
next population there'll be some
individual that's maximally diverse from
all of the individuals that have been
selected for the next generation so far
so where would what kind of individual
would you like to pick for the next
generation well the one with the highest
Fitness rank and the one with the
highest diversity rank so what you
really like because you'd like to have
somebody right there
and if you can't have somebody right
there if there's nobody right there with
maximum with a maximum fitness a maximum
diversity at the same time then maybe
you can draw an ISO goodness lines like
so which is just how far you are from
that ideal so let's summarize
you got to pick some individuals for the
next population when we pick the first
individual all we got to go on is is is
how fit the individual is because
there's nobody else to that next
generation after the first first
individual is selected then we can look
at our set of candidates and we can say
which candidate would be more different
from the set of things we've already
selected than all the others that would
get the highest diversity rank and so on
down the candidate list so let's see how
that might work
so we're going to use a combination of
Fitness rank and diversity rank and
we'll just use this simple one so far
use a small step size and we'll let this
run a hundred generations to see what
happens bingo it crawls right up there
because it's trying to keep itself
spread out uses the diversity
measurement to do that at the same time
it's seeking high Fitness so that's why
it's crawling up the upper right hand
corner but in the end that diversity
piece of it is keeping the things spread
out so suppose you're a shark or
something you don't care about diversity
anymore and we can just turn that off
that thing's still running go back to
fitness rank bingo so there you are your
stuff for 600 million years so let's see
if this will handle the moat problem
see our step size is still small we'll
just let this run so the diversity of
piece of us keeping it spread out pretty
soon bingo it's all right it's right in
there even it's across that big moat
because it's got the cross over a
mechanism that combines the best of the
excess and the best of the wise so that
seems to work like work pretty well okay
so see these are some of the these are
some of the things that you can think
about when you're thinking oh of course
we're shark we're going to forget about
diversity we'll change the selection
method from fittest and diversity rank
to just diversity ater collapses down on
to the highest hill yeah
meatball what oh I see your question is
how the step size translate into
mutation Oh instead of allowing myself
to take steps as big as 1/10 I might
allow myself to take steps as big as
3/10 according to some distribution so
what to say about all this it's um it's
a very seductive because it's nature
right the trouble is it's naive nature
and this is a as evolutionary theories
go this is horrible this is naive so
we'd like to use real evolutionary
theory except we don't have real
evolutionary theory evolution is still a
mystery some things are pretty obvious
you can you can you can breed fast
racehorses that works just like so the
trouble is we don't have any real good
idea about how speciation takes place
and how a lot of evolution works because
all these chromosomes are connected to
their phenotype consequences in very
complicated ways that nobody fully
understands so there's a great deal of
magic in that genotype to phenotype
transition that nobody really
understands very well so when people
write these programs that do
that that are in the in the style of
so-called genetic algorithm that they're
taking they're out taking a photograph
of high school biology and and they're
spending a long time building programs
based on that naive idea but that night
that naive idea have root has lots of
places for intervention because you can
look at all the things you can screw
around with in that in that process of
going from one generation to the next
you got by the way what is mutation do
it's basically hill climbing right it's
producing a little spread out and you're
using the fitness thing to climb the
hill so you get a lot of choices about
how you handle that then you get a lot
of choices on how much crossover you do
and what does crossover do kind of
combines features of strong features of
multiple individuals into one individual
maybe so you got all kinds of choices
there and then your genotype to
phenotype translation how do you
interpret something like those zeros and
ones as an if-then rule for example is
something that's in the hands of the
designer and then you got the rest of
those things all of which are left up to
the designer so in the end you really
have to ask when you see an impressive
demonstration you have to say where does
the credit lie and I mean that pun
intentionally because usually the people
who are claiming the credit are lying
about where it's coming from but
nevertheless let me give you a couple of
examples of where this has found actual
bona fide a practical application so
when you look for a practical
application you might say well where in
what kind of problem does a good front
piece combine with a good back piece to
produce a good thing overall and the
answer is when you're making a plan so
you might have a problem in planning
that requires you to take a series of
steps
and you might have two plans each of
which is a series of steps and you might
combine these to produce something new
that's the front half of one and the
back half of another that's practical
application number one and that requires
you to interpret your chromosome as an
indicator of the steps in a plant but
another example comes up is them drawn
from them
you're our project a student did for me
some years ago came to me and said he's
a freshman he came to me and said I want
to do your art project I said have you
taken six hours before and he said no
and I said go away and he said I don't
want to go away I don't want to do
Europe projects so I said have you read
my book he said no I said we'll go away
then and he said I don't want to go away
I want to do Europe project so I said I
don't have any year off projects he said
that's okay I've got my own and it and
he was interested
he's a finance type guy so he was
interested in whether he could build a
rule-based expert system that could
predict the winners at horse races so
his real basic first system consisted of
rules like this if x and y then some
conclusion if l and m then some kind of
conclusion and from these he would
produce rules like if X Prime that's a
slightly mutated version of the of the X
antecedent and M and some conclusion so
it's mutation and crossover and he was
able to produce a system that seemed to
work as not as well as the handicappers
in the newspapers so he started losing
money at a less fast rate he is now
doing something in the stock market they
say doesn't talk so much about it though
but an interesting interesting
application it came up with rules like
if the sum of the jockeys weight and the
post position is low that's good well
that makes sense in the end because the
jockeys weight is always between 100 110
pounds of the post positions always
between 1 and 10 or something so they
were kind of commitment values and a low
one is good in fact not bad
but neither of those I mean this is this
is real stuff my company uses this sort
of stuff to do to do some planning work
but you know those is as impressive as a
demonstration I'm about to show you that
involves the evolution of creatures and
these creatures consists of block-like
objects like so and they combine like
this and so on and so how can you make a
creature like that from zero one
chromosome well some of the bits in the
chromosome are our interpreter is the
number of objects others are interpreted
as the sizes of the objects others are
interpreted as the structure of how the
objects are articulated and still others
are interpreted as fixing the control
algorithm by which the creature operates
so you see how that roughly goes would
you like to see a film of that in action
yes
so always likes to see the films I
question is how do I measure the
diversity of the graph I did I did it
the same way I measure the fitness that
is to say I calculated the the distance
the actual metric distance of all of the
candidates for the next generation from
all of the candidates had already been
selected I summed that up and from this
um I could rank them according to how
different they were from the individuals
that are already in the next generation
so it is in your rank and then from the
rank I use that kind of calculations to
determine a fitness
probability of survival then I just
combine the two kinds of probabilities
you always kept like every time you see
the people the individuals have already
been selected at every step so every
step is a little different because it's
working with a new set of individuals
that have already been selected for next
generation all right so let's see how
this works so this is showing the
evolution of some swimming creatures and
they're evolved according to how well
they can swim how fast they can go some
of them have quite exotic mechanisms and
some of them quite naturally look like a
sperm saw floating away there once you
have these things evolving then of
course you can get groups of them to
evolve together so you saw already some
that were that we're evolving to swim
these are evolving to move around on the
land it's interesting this was done by
Karl Sims who at the time was at a then
thriving company Thinking Machines the
first spinoff from MIT so he was using a
vastly parallel computer super powerful
for its day thousands of processors to
do this it was a demonstration of what
you could do with lots of computing in
the early stages of the experimentation
though its notion of physics wasn't
quite complete so some of the creatures
evolved to move by hitting themselves in
the chest and not knowing about the
conservation of momentum
I thought that was just great so here
they are out doing some further so you
look at these you saying wow there must
be something to this this is interesting
these are complicated this one I think
this is one of the ones that was trained
of it initially to swim and then to do a
LAN locomotion
so eventually Carl got around to
thinking about how to make these things
evolve so they would compete for food
that's the fastest I think by the way of
the LAN Local Motors something that was
that was training them to evolving them
to jump this is evolving them to follow
a little red dot some have quite exotic
method have stumble across otic methods
ish you can see I seem to be flailing
around it somehow managed
sort of like watching people take a quiz
making progress on but now we're on to
the food competition
so some of them go for the food and some
of them go to excluding the ER their
opponent from the food not actually
caring too much about whether they get
it it's sort of a children do there's a
kind of there's a kind of hockey hockey
player now here's two hockey players
watch this face one succeeds reminds me
a little bit of hockey rugby something
like that sometimes they just kind of
get kind of confused go right after
their opponent forgetting about the coin
gives up these are I think these were
overall winners in this elimination
contest I can't quite get there okay so
you look at that and you say wow that's
cool genetic algorithms must be the way
to go I remember the first time I saw
this film that was over in kreski I was
walking out of the auditorium with
Tommaso pazzo and we looked at each
other and we said the same thing
simultaneously we didn't say that
genetic algorithms are the way to go all
we said was
wow that space is rich in solutions but
we were amazed by was not the gem it
that simple-minded genetic algorithms
produce solutions but that the space was
so rich with solutions that almost any
mechanism that was looking around and
that's
would find them but there's yet another
way of thinking about and that is you
could say wow look at how smart Carl
Sims is because Carl Sims is the one who
had his hands all the levers all those
choices and I keep that I kept
emphasizing all of those choices that
enabled him to trick this thing in some
sense into stumbling across the the
solutions in a space that was guaranteed
to be rich with solutions so you have to
ask so first of all diversity is good we
noticed that but we put diversity into
the genetic algorithm calculations we
were much better at finding solutions
but the next go star idea that I really
liked have you go away with is the idea
that you have to ask where the credit
lies does it lie with the ingenuity of
the programmer or with the value of the
algorithm itself in this case impressive
as it is the credit lies and the
richness of the space and in the
intelligence of the programmer not
necessarily in the idea of genetic
algorithms
you